in this lesson we're going to talk about
factoring and some typical examples that
you may see on the act in regards to
factoring so let's just look at a couple
of formulas here first
one that you might know from your
previous algebra class is a squared
minus b squared this is called the
difference of two squares and when you
factor it it factors as a sum and a
difference pattern so a plus b times a
minus b so an example would be like if
you had x squared minus 81 x x squared
is a perfect square and 81 is a perfect
square so you would factor this as x
plus 9
times x minus 9 okay now if it was an
equation where this was equal to 0
then what you would do is you would set
each factor each group equal to 0 and
solve so we'd say x plus 9 equals 0 and
x minus 9 equals 0 and solve
now in this one here this is a trinomial
three terms and what you can do is you
can think about doing the foil the first
outer inner last in reverse so what
you're doing with the foil in reverse is
you're saying to yourself okay let me
see if i can factor this into two
binomials so the first term times the
first term gives us this first term here
so the only way to get x squared is x
times x then we jump to the last term
okay negative 12 if we multiply these
two last terms together what multiplies
to negative 12
but it adds to this middle coefficient
negative one well you can see that's
going to be negative four and positive
three and if you multiply all this out
by either distributing or doing the foil
method you're going to see negative 4x
and positive 3x adds up to negative 1x
negative 4 times positive 3 is negative
12 and the x times x is x squared then
all you have to do is set each group
equal to 0 so we have x minus 4 equals
zero and x plus three equals zero if we
add four to both sides we get x equals
four if we subtract three from both
sides we get x equals negative three
so just a little review of factoring you
might wanna take a look at that a little
bit closer
understanding some of the basic ideas
behind factoring but let's go through
some examples go ahead and pause the
video and see if you can do these on
your own and we'll cover them together
so it says what are the solutions to 4x
squared minus 20x equals zero
well the first step in factoring
is the greatest common factor so you see
is there something i can divide out of
both of these terms well it looks like
they're both divisible by 4x so if i can
divide out a 4x i'm left with x minus 5.
so now it's factored we can set 4x equal
to zero and x minus five equal to zero
and if we do that we're gonna get x
equals zero and here we're gonna get x
equals five so those are our solutions
so
with factoring the first thing you wanna
remember is the greatest common factor
to divide out that greatest common
factor
this one it says example two what are
the solutions to this one well they've
already factored this for us okay so all
we have to do is set each group
equal to zero so we have two x minus a
equals zero and x plus
b equals 0. so i subtract b from both
sides you can see x equals negative b
and here if we add a to both sides
we have 2x equals a divide by 2 so x
equals a over 2. so these would be your
two solutions to example two so
factoring is you know important concept
you want to understand
so review that a little bit further but
pay attention to some of these concepts
here about setting the factors to zero
once you factor to solve so i'll see you
in the next lesson